leave out tell me about what happened
yesterday yesterday was packed with
action there are two subtypes one and a
hundred meters and one and three hundred
meters and ever I hadn't yet made my
first dive but I'm looking forward to
that today but the news is really
wonderful in addition to the sub ties
there were scuba dives I made two of
those two nicely returns for me to cook
books to meet some old friends and find
some new ones too we found a turtle that
had a tag on the satellite tag
journal actually was a Hawksbill that
had apparently been distressed by its
contact with human beings in fact seemed
to be a pretty friendly turtle lots of
pictures were taken and we it a big
smile and it gave us a turtle smile back
to about the end of the blue so
somebody's checking that turtle I hope
that we find out who it is and make
contact and we let me know your turtle
so what's what's coming up today with
this up you're going to be going into it
today Bruce Robison and I will be making
a descent we our destination is about
300 meters about a thousand feet down in
a place that has only been looked at a
couple of times we expect to find some
new things and we get to see some old
friends yesterday when Gideon Jorge
first hey guys named after the sailfish
came by that is so unusual to see of
salvation didn't linger and took off we
don't know what we're going to see
either in mid-water were as we dive
along the bottom
this is really good information this is
on a part of the Cocos Island area that
is a little tricky to get to it's not
where people have been going
historically the subs very often so
we're looking for some good information
to help establish how really special
focuses
you